Let's go through more
exponent examples.
So to warm up, let's think
about taking a fraction
to some power.
So let's say I have
2/3, and I want
to raise it to the
third power here.
Now, we've already
learned there are
two ways of thinking about this.
One way is to say
let's take three 2/3's.
So that's one 2/3, two
2/3's, and three 2/3's.
So that's one, two, three, 2/3.
And then we multiply them.
And we will get-- let's
see, the numerator
will be 2 times 2
times 2, which is 8.
And the denominator's
going to be 3 times 3 times
3 times 3, which is equal to 27.
Now, the other way of viewing
this is you start with a 1,
and you multiply it
by 2/3 three times.
So you multiply by 2/3
once, twice, three times.
You will get the exact
same result here.
So let's do one more
example like that.
So lets say I had 4/9,
and I want to square it.
When I raise something
to the second power,
people often say,
you're squaring it.
Also, raising something
to the third power,
people sometimes say,
you're cubing it.
But let's raise 4/9
to the second power.
Let's square it.
And I encourage you
to pause the video
and work this out yourself.
Well, once again,
you could view this
as taking two 4/9's
and multiplying them.
Or you could view this
as starting with a 1,
and multiplying it
by 4/9 two times.
Either way, your
numerator is going
to be 4 times 4, which is 16.
And your denominator
is going to be
9 times 9, which is equal to 81.